this video it's gonna be talking all
about the busiest week of my PhD so far
and about a million different things
plus some homework for you which I
actually think you're really gonna enjoy
this video is brought to you by the
motion picture Birdman in your video if
you're watching please do get in touch
because I need you to pay me for the
sponsorship man so there were like a
million and one different things going
on in my life at the moment and they're
all kind of culminating in this week so
this video is gonna be a bit frantic
there gonna be loads and loads talk
about so let's get going
one thing before we start though you
might notice that this video looks and
sounds a bit different than normal
that's because I don't have any of my
kid I'm currently filming this in my
room
with my backup set which is my by g7x
because all my regular stuff is on
campus but you'll notice that if I show
you on this filthy mirror you're being
lit by a desk lamp I'm doing my best now
covering toilet paper so yeah necessity
is the mother of invention first things
first I wanted to talk quickly about the
response to my last vlog where I
basically asked you about the content
I'm putting out in terms the climate and
stuff it's great to hear everyone's been
getting the videos and I've been taking
on board everything that people what
people even saying in the comments which
is basically the YouTube report isn't
the best format for the kind of videos
which I'm doing which is intense you
know scientific stuff that people come
back at the end of the day and they want
something a bit more a edutainment which
is like what youtubers call it and that
stuff which I got planned in the coming
year basically I wanted to do the crash
courses like tests see if if it would
work and you know I've got valuable data
on that and I'm taking what you guys say
on board you know I'm trying to I am
doing the stuff which I want to do but
at the same time I've got to be
realistic in terms of what people are
actually gonna watch so you know it's
like a balancing act but I'm still gonna
do my thing if you enjoy watching this
and I'm still gonna do vlogs there's
gonna be a massive mix of stuff on this
this channel much more than in the past
so hope there be something that tickles
your fancy one new thing in particular
that it's body worth talking about is
the battlefront video which I put out
that was it was great to do to my friend
John properly even if it was just us
being salty together now if you like
that and it seems based on the comments
he did comment down below if you'd like
more because we would over the Christmas
period basically we were thinking of
possibly recording just a couple of
short games and either getting really
salty again or just talking about stuff
because he's like my best mate and I
thought I think you'd be interesting so
yeah if you'd like the idea of me
about fur and stuff then do common or
equal if you don't want me clogging up
your subscription fee with stuff you're
not going to watch then say that as well
yeah there's gonna be mix of stuff so
there is going to be that entertainment
stuff and there's a whole bunch of
different scripts which I got planned
out including one which based on my
Twitter I know people are interested win
which is my favorite books and one
reading the moment so I mentioned
earlier this week coming up is the most
intense week of my PhD to date and the
main reason for that is that in terms of
work I'm going to this big conference in
America and San Francisco called the
American Geophysical Union fall 2015
meeting and I'm presenting a poster
which is basically I was talking to talk
about this and enology he had is a bit
like you're in a market like everybody
has their another market stall and I'm
trying to sell my wares my wares does
happen to be my research and
stratosphere troposphere coupling so I'm
presenting there and as I mentioned in
the last video I got this quite good
result out the whole point of me doing
what I'm doing is as a test of a theory
like a hypothesis and I basically got to
the point where I could almost make like
a detestable thing out of my work I
don't wanna be any more technical mess
because it's late
but not quite and my supervisors just
pushed me to get that next mathematical
step done unfortunately that next
mathematical step is quite complicated
so even though is currently Sunday it's
like 8 o'clock I just got back from the
office so there's a lot of work pressure
this week like this is a this is a now
or never situation in terms of this work
which means both solving a nonlinear
second order PDE and trying to make some
some kind of physical sense of that in
two different coordinate systems I'm
also gonna be doing some statistical
stuff and like using a whole bunch of
different skills I've learned from my
degrees plural so yeah it's quite a lot
on at the moment if you'd like to learn
more about my work then I'm going to be
tweeting a lot this week and some Knox
beers on Twitter I tweet a lot anyway
because I procrastinate too much but I
will try and my best khaki you guys
updated with where I'm at in terms of
work so yeah go for that the next reason
that this week is going to be so
incredibly intense because this week is
the cop21 meeting in Paris so this is
the big climate change meeting that I've
been making videos about recently if you
haven't seen those gonna check them out
there in a placement description and
this is this is usually this is a really
really big deal so I'm gonna be trying
to keep you guys again on my Twitter and
on my Facebook up to date with what the
latest kind of news is I'm also gonna be
trying to get videos out if I
and every day based on these uh visitor
with climate professors you know if
that's the kind of thing then there's
gonna be loads and loads of content on
that but like I say it's not going to be
everything on my channel don't worry
and yeah this is this is a hugely
significant week this is of this is
really big and it and you need to
educate yourself about this because this
could be talked about for generations so
as well as doing some of the most
technical maths of my PhD I'm also going
to be trying to follow along with one of
the biggest political meetings of our
generation on the sidelines but the
really big thing that's gonna add to the
stress this week is singing and this is
where the homework comes in so if you
follow me for quite some time you will
know that I am a singer in the
University of Exeter Chapel Choir so
that means that I sing every week in
liturgical services and that's like even
songs and new Christian tents normally
we get through a back incredible
turnover of music that only gets added
to in the run-up to Christmas to give
you an idea this is currently Sunday
yesterday we sight-read melanson's
elijah in a performance for with alumni
today we then in the morning did a
regular Eucharist with his whacking
great big mass then tomorrow we're
singing in the university forum for the
telling one of the Christmas lights
Tuesday we actually have off then
Wednesday we have a service Thursday
before rehearsal Friday we have a car
service Saturday we're doing filming
Sunday we're doing a concert I think
we're doing something on the Monday of
that and it's I'm gonna have a voice
span into this this is where the
homework comes in right because when
people think of Christmas music they
think of a few carols I think of a way
in a manger a little town of Bethlehem
Silent Night you know it's all quite
standard stuff the hitchhiked out every
every year and now it's quite nice you
know but having its now started singing
because I didn't sing before I came to
Exeter and ie in the past two years have
been made aware of this like whole new
world of music that's really really good
that's read about Christmas so what I've
done is I have made a playlist which I
put in the description and it'll be on
screen right here of interesting
Christmas music and what I want you to
do and I mean you even especially if you
don't think this is your kind of music
or if you're not from a Christian
background you don't know what any
Chryst like Christmas music is like
that's not pop music I wait to garnish
playlists and to remove bias say click
shuffle and I want you to listen to the
pieces because there's there's not that
many there's like I don't know 20 I
think
necessarily want to listen to all of
them I wait to get some of them ago and
comment down below in this video which
one is your favorite there is so much
amazing music and it is people just
don't know it so I want you and I mean
this I want you to go and listen to this
music have it in the background they say
takes your eye or even your ear I went
to comment and I want you guys to you
know talk to me and each other in the
comments about which pieces you like and
why and if you don't like them or if you
don't like any of them comment below
with why because this is a huge like
it's been a huge deal for me learning
about this stuff I had no clue and I've
been introduced I've been feel really
lucky to have been introduced to this
music I want to share that with you
because some of this stuff is the most
beautiful music I've ever heard and I
want you guys to have that experience
too and as if that wasn't enough it's
also the project for awesome coming out
so the project for awesome fuzzy the
don't know is a charity event on YouTube
every year where we raise money for
charities and basically you she was make
videos about their charity of choice and
the videos which get the most of votes
on the project for awesome website get a
cut of the money raised and I'm going to
be supporting Daryl this year I did this
last year and actually went there and
made some videos for them and about them
I've loved about it there's again I look
up there's me so lonely links in the
description up on screen and down there
and I'm gonna be doing two or three
videos going into December so the actual
project for awesome is on December 11th
December 12 that's when I'll be putting
my video to try and raise money for
Daryl and to get people to vote for it
up but before that only be putting some
videos up about the work that they do
there's some more conservation charity
they do some most important work in the
world those videos coming up dennis the
project for awesome all of those I would
I would fastly appreciate you sharing
because there's so much more important
than me there's so much so much a bigger
issue than me so thank you in advance
thank you thank you thank you for
sharing this videos see ya let's see if
I can remember this all if you want more
bash different videos with John and I
just talking about stuff then please
comment below make sure you go and look
at that singing playlist of choral music
about Christmas comment below with which
one piece is your favorite you know just
have a listen to a few and shuffle where
the project for awesome please come out
make sure you share them - thinks I've
got a list I've had so much to talk
about I've actually had to write it down
normally keep it all up here follow me
on Twitter if you're interested in my
PhD stuff
if you're interested in cop21 which you
should be then go and check out the
videos that I've been making if you're
not interested in cop21 become
interested in cop21 and have pity for me
because I'm probably going to be dead
from all the work and lack of sleep this
week thank you for watching
that's enough to be getting on with my
skip end there's something I want to
talk to you about it's name is jazz it's
not John Cena I want to talk to you
about this is not the time to introduce
science it's interesting thing but it's
off believe it you know when you're in a
negotiation say you're buying a t-shirt
or market stuff you don't want someone
to come in and say oh by the way the
real value of that t-shirt is three
pounds just about